if people could understand
that
this is the kin to the scariest thing
you've ever done
then they'll start to understand why
we're so addicted to it
when i put the goggles on the first
thing i'm doing is trying to calm down
it totally puts you inside the drone you
just forget where you are
i'm conrad miller also known as ferrari
and i'm a drone racer
i started in september 2014 and that was
like the ground floor
of all the activities i've partaken in
motorcycles and flying drones are on the
same level in terms of intensity
it's cool when you have a hobby and you
can do it and you love it but when you
can share it with your kids i mean
that's just you know that's just like
what it's all about i think okay so
props are good
flying and racing with sorel has just
been a pure joy he's a good kid and he's
a talented kid and i think it comes easy
to set any kid like that because they
don't feel the pressure that adults do
good landing
coming in hot
this is harder than anything else i've
done and it's because when you're when
your nerves go your fine motor skills go
kids don't care they're having fun
and they just learn much faster
the course in la is at the hawthorne
mall which is abandoned it's been
abandoned since the 80s i believe and it
looks like a place where you would go if
there was a zombie apocalypse
when i go into races i feel like i put
a lot of pressure on myself to win
you know i want all of my
practice and all of my
time flying to show up or something
i was flying fine i wasn't nervous but i
was just a little too high and crashed
you like almost hit the ceiling you're
like
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it
and it's just going to get tougher and
tougher i take that 180 good yeah you
did flying with swell now it kind of
gives me an opportunity to look at it
from a different perspective because i
can coach him ready
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do he's flying a drone which is
this groundbreaking thing
we hate each other you hit me what are
you talking about we hit each other you
know as parents we don't always feel
like we do enough i brought him into
drone racing and he knows he's lucky and
he knows he's fortunate yeah kiddo
you're going pretty quick and you know
he's just he's grateful for everything
that he gets
you